Morgan is on Facebook and says Dave if
you really believe people shouldn't use
credit cards why does your website take
credit cards hmm Morgan obviously you're
an idiot because there's a couple of
things you underestimated by trolling my
facebook page with your hip hypocritical
innuendo the thing you didn't understand
about me is I am NOT your typical person
that's on the air I'm a hillbilly and
when you insult a Hillbillies honor and
integrity we get pissed off and
Hillbillies don't do drive-by shootings
we buy the house next door to you and
lay siege so you need to understand you
little twit with your digital courage
and your you know obvious sleight of my
integrity that number one you're an
idiot number two you don't know what
you're talking about my website does not
take credit cards we very clearly take
debit cards it would be hypocritical for
us to take credit cards now
can you run a credit card through our
website system possibly it could
probably happen with the software I
don't know but we have clear signage up
that says don't do that you fool and
that we're not hypocrites so if you
really want to find some excuse to not
do the stuff we're talking about Morgan
there's lots of excuses but my lack of
integrity is not on the list because we
are exactly who we say we are I'm worth
tens of millions of dollars because I do
the stuff we talk about my wife still
has a freaking envelope system in her
purse we do not take credit cards we do
not borrow money I had a guy asked me
this morning I was in a meeting he goes
hey my wife's a teacher up in Gallatin
Tennessee she heard you least
truck and I'm like a hard cheese kind of
idiot would I be to go lease a truck and
what kind of [ __ ] at a car dealership
actually tells somebody the Dave Ramsey
leased his car I mean that's you have to
be beyond stupid to think that I would
lease a car I mean seriously
but everybody you know here's what it is
you don't want to grow up you don't want
to live on less than you make you don't
want to get on a budget you don't want
to agree on your spending with your
spouse you don't want to stop spending
like you're in Congress you don't want
to quit being a little twit and so you
try to find something inconsistent about
me listen if you don't want to do the
stuff we teach okay I still got
financial piece you just go on your
merry stupid little way I'm fine if you
don't want it this stuff we teach
whoever you are if you're insulted or
you don't like my politics right on time
of air or you got a face for radio or
whatever you can find a reason to not
follow Dave Ramsey there's lots of them
you're too angry you're not mean enough
you're you're too Christian you're not
Christian enough there's always a reason
to not do this stuff if you want an
excuse to not fix your life but that's
all it is darling you're just being a
little twit and you're this generation
that has what we call digital courage
you know more would walk into the lobby
of this building and say something
stupid but like that to my face then fly
to the moon and if you did then we would
have to help you leave the building
quicker than you beat might carry you so
unbelievable but you like that kind of
courage you're just a little little
spineless little boy living in his
mother's basement and so go on social
media with your little opinion but now
darling we don't take credit cards we're
not inconsistent you know don't least
much rock no mortgage on my house Oh
Lord and I don't have secret investments
in double secret double backflip family
partnerships then only the rich Hughes
there's no such thing by the way you
stupid people seriously just do the
stuff man
just do the stuff this is the Dave
Ramsey show